翻訳: Noriaki Ohta
校正: Hiroko Kawano
あなたと建築したい
神戸の皆様 初めまして こんにちは
（拍手）
ありがとうございます
初めまして 私 東京大学
吉備 友理恵（きびゆりえ）と申します
私 東京藝術大学の
都築 響子（つづききょうこ）と申します
２人で建築ユニット『esquisse』
というのをやっております
よろしくお願いいたします
（拍手）
ありがとうございます
突然ですがここで問題です
これ なーんだ？
わかる方 会場にいらっしゃいますか？
今 お姉さん 大きな声で
(聴衆) ポートタワー
わーい 大正解 (拍手)
神戸ということで ポートタワーを
載せてきちゃいました
私たちは普段 建築を学ぶ学生です
でも 街を歩いたり
このようなイベントに出させていただくとき
頭の上に建築を載せています
このように 今までも
たくさんの「頭上建築」をしてきました
奇抜な格好をしていると
目に入ってきてしまいますよね
「え？ あれ何？」といった感じに
これが私たちの発信方法です
目立つものに
目がいってしまうのと同じように
普段気づかないものに対しても
気づいて欲しい
それが私たちの狙いです
建築ってなんだか専門的だったり
難しいなと思う方も
多いんじゃないでしょうか？
今 人々と建築が離れてしまっています
硬く難しそうな建築を
広く柔らかい「ケンチク」に変えたいのです
まず これを見てください
これが何かわかる方
いらっしゃいますでしょうか？
少し引いて見てみましょう
気づいた方も —
あんまり 思ったよりいない
もう少し引いてみましょう
バナナでした
このように身近なものも近すぎると
気づかないことってよくあると思います
建築もそうなんです
建築って皆さんを包み込むくらい大きくて
一目で全貌を把握するのが難しいです
なので 近すぎて気づかない状態と
同じようになりがちなんです
では 建築というものはどんなものがあるのか
例を見ていってみましょう
これは建築です
これも建築です
これも建築なんです
皆さんは今の５つの例を見て
どう思われましたか？
最後の２つを見て
「あれ？これも建築なの？」と
思われた方も多いんじゃないでしょうか？
でも最後の２つも歴とした建築なんです
あなたの生まれた町も
あなたの住んでいる家も
お気に入りのカフェも
時たま行くピクニックも
毎日飲むコーヒーだって
全てが「場」を作っています
その「場」を作っているものが
私たちの考える
広く柔らかい建築です
それでは これを知ったところで
どんな良いことがあるのでしょうか？
幾つか例をあげていきたいと思います
今日はTEDxYouth@Kobeということで
若いお客さんも
たくさんいらっしゃるように見受けれらます
なので 気になるあの人に
好きになってもらえるかもしれない
建築の話をしたいと思います
想像してみてください
気になるあの子と晩ごはんデートです
案内された横並びの席には
テーブルの右端にキャンドルが灯っています
あなたは右の席と左の席
どちらを選びますか？
正解は左の席です
人間の身体は暗いところを見るとき
瞳孔が開きます
他にも目の瞳孔が開くときがあります
それは好きな人を見るときです
右側の相手はあなたの方を見るときに
暗い方を見ることになります
すると目の瞳孔が開きます
身体は勘違いをしてあなたを見たときに
瞳孔が開いていると認識します
（笑）
するとあなたのことが好きなのかも
と錯覚してしまうのです
このように建築を味方につけると
あなたの恋が叶う可能性が
ちょっと上がったりします
もちろん相手との相性や
相手のことを思いやる気持ちが
一番大切なのは変わりありません
そろそろ引っ越しのシーズンですよね
皆さん家を探される時
どういったところを お気になさいますか？
やっぱり間取りって気になりませんか？
ここに自分の気に入った
全く同じ間取りの部屋が２つあります
立地や値段で選ぶ方も
もちろんいると思います
でもこの２つの部屋
実は 天井の高さが違うんです
天井の高いお部屋は人が開放的になり
創造力も豊かになります
対して天井の低いお部屋は安心感があり
集中をした作業に向いている環境になります
あなたが暮らす その暮らし方によって
天井の高さというものを意識して
部屋を選んでみてもいいかもしれません
このように建築は単なる箱と
捉えるのではなく
建築をその色々な場を作るもの
そして人と人の関係を作るもの
というふうに認識をすると
皆さんにとって
たくさんの良いことがあります
でも 建築が人の無意識に影響することって
とっても多く 馬鹿にできません
でも こういったことを私たちが
セミナーを開いてお話ししたとしても
建築に興味のある人しか
話を聞きに来てくれません
それでは意味がないんです
私たちは今ある硬く難しい建築の概念を
柔らかく広い概念に変えたいのです
そのためには皆さんに少しでも
興味を持っていただく必要があります
なので私たちは自らが広告塔となり
皆さんの注意を引きたいのです
建築の雑誌を開いてみたり
出かける先をこだわってみたり
自分の部屋を工夫してみたり
そこまでいかなくてもほんのちょっと
建築に目が行くだけでいいんです
そういう影響が生まれると
私たちはとても嬉しいです
私たちは建築の問題を
私たちにしかできない方法で発信しています
皆さんは何を発信しますか？
「問題だな」と思っていること
「人に伝えたいな」と思っていることは
ありませんか？
それをどうやって発信しますか？
SNSもあります
ブログもあります
ホームページも簡単に
作れるようになってきました
今 世界中の若者たちは自分なりの方法で
社会に対してメッセージを発信しています
今 世の中はオリジナルの発信方法を
認め始めています
「変な奴らだ」と敬遠されてしまうことも
あるかもしれませんが
少なくなってきているんじゃないでしょうか？
今 時代は個性を受け入れる
フェーズにきています
私たちはこれからも自らが広告塔となり
メッセージを発信し続けます
皆さんは何をどうやって発信しますか？
ありがとうございました
(拍手)